now i'm going to show you a circuit
that's called a voltage divider this is
a name we give to a simple circuit of
two
series resistors so i'm just going to
draw two series resistors here
and it's a nickname in the sense of it's
just a pattern that we see when
we look at circuits and
i'll show you what the pattern is the
pattern is
we have
two resistors in series it's no more
than that
and we assume that there's a voltage
over here
we hook up a voltage over here like this
so that's that's called an input voltage
we'll call it v i for v in
and then the midpoint of the two
resistors and typically the bottom
that's called v out so we basically
just have a pattern here with a series
resistor driven by some voltage from the
ends of the two resistors and we're
curious about the voltage across one of
them so now we're going to develop an
expression for this
let's also let's also label our
resistors this will be r1
and this will be r2
that's how we tell our resistors apart
and we're going to develop an expression
for this
so
let's first put a current through here
we'll call that current i
will make an assumption that this
current here is is zero there's no
current going out of our little circuit
here and that means of course that this
current here is also i
so it's continuous all the way down
and now we want to develop an expression
that tells us what v out is in terms of
these two resistors
and the input voltage so let's go over
here and do that
first thing we're going to write is we
know that
using ohm's law we can write an
expression for
these series resistors on this side here
ohm's law we'll put over here
v equals i
r
in the specific case here
v n
equals i times what times the series
combination of r1 and r2
and the series combination is the sum r1
plus r2
i'm going to solve this for i i equals
vn
divided by
r1 plus r2
all right next step is going to be let's
solve for let's write an expression
that's related to v out
and v out only depends on r 2 and this
current here so we can write v out
equals i
times r 2.
and i'll solve this equation for i the
same way
equals
v zero over r2
and now we have two expressions for i
in our circuit because we made this
assumption of zero current going out
those two i's are the same so let's set
those equal to each other
and see what we get
i
is
v
0 over r 2
equals
v 1
over r 1 plus r 2.
so now i'm going to take r2 and move it
over to the other side of the equation
and we get
v out
equals
v1
sorry vi vn
times
r2
over
r1
plus r2
and this is called
this is called the voltage divider
expression right here
it gives us a expression for v out in
terms of v in and the ratio of resistors
resistors are always positive numbers
and so this fraction is always a
less than one
which means that v out is always
somewhat less than v in and it's
adjustable by adjusting the resistor
values it's a really handy circuit to
have
let's do some examples we'll put that up
in the corner so we can see it
i'm going to real quick i'm going to
build a voltage divider that we can
practice on
let's make this 2k
ohms 2000 ohms we'll make this
6000 ohms or 6k
ohms
and we'll hook it up to
an input source that looks like
let's say it's 6 volts
like that
and we'll take an output off of this
right here
is where the output of our voltage
divider is
and we'll say that that is
v out v out
so let's solve this using the voltage
divider expression
v out
equals
v n which is six volts
times the ratio of resistors and the re
r2 is
6 k ohms
divided by
2 k ohms
plus
6 k ohms
and notice this always happens the k's
all cancel out that's nice
and that equals
6 times
6 over 2 plus 6 is 8.
and if i do my calculations right
v out is
4.5
volts
so that's what a voltage divider is and
as you if you remember at the beginning
if you remember at the beginning we made
an assumption
that this current going out here was a
pro
about zero
if that current is really small you can
use this voltage divider expression
which as we see up here is the ratio of
the bottom resistor to both resistors
that's how i remember it it's the bottom
resistor over the two resistors added
together
if you think the current is not very
small what you do is you go back and you
do this analysis that you do the same
analysis again but you account for the
current that's in here
so that's the story on voltage dividers